the Netherlands is known as a cyclists
paradise it's safety levels one of the
best in the world are in staggering
contrast with the US where you're around
20 times more likely to be injured while
riding a bike in the Dutch capital
nearly half the working population
commutes daily on over 500 kilometers of
dedicated cycling paths but the city
only narrowly avoided being taken over
by cars here's how Amsterdam put the
brakes on cars to give bikes a chance
following the Second World War the
mobility and affordability of cars
started changing people's lives
neighborhoods around the world have been
flattened to make way for busy highways
New York striving to keep abreast of the
ceaseless teeming traffic amsterdam
wasn't gonna be left behind streets once
considered public space in the
netherlands were changing their new
function was purely for traffic the
number of bikes in amsterdam plummeted
between 1960 and 1970 the number of cars
in the country quadrupled jamming the
traditionally narrow streets engineers
and city planners wanted to modernize
apps them to make it more car friendly
they proposed ideas like filling in the
famous canals with concrete leveling
historic neighborhoods and building
expressways and monorails
this is what Amsterdam would have looked
like in 2000 if the Dust Brothers had
realized their futuristic vision
unsurprisingly
there was opposition anarchist group
Provo came up with the world's first
biking car sharing schemes that in
takeoff at the time but the sentiment to
keep Amsterdam light on cars was shared
Dutch road fatalities peaked in 1972 in
response protest groups like stop the
kinder mod or stop murdering children
were organizing blockades of areas with
high accident rates to make their point
then in 1973 the oil crisis sent fuel
prices skyward prompting the Dutch
government to ban motor vehicles for one
day a week reaction here to the Sunday
motoring ban has been mixed the unions
and the hoteliers are angry and annoyed
that the sales of bicycles started to
rise
pressure groups jumped at the
opportunity to show citizens how
Amsterdam could look without cars the
government took notice and in 1978
introduced the traffic circulation plan
to make Amsterdam less attractive to
drivers it called for the closure of
certain streets to traffic reduction in
car parking spaces and gave priority to
cyclists and pedestrians Amsterdam
started embracing Vaughn F or living
Street a concept that was already
successful in reducing traffic
casualties outside of the capital
especially designed zones a landscape to
slow drivers down without sidewalks
drivers share the space with cyclists
and pedestrians and have to move at
walking pace making Amsterdam more bike
friendly was really about making the
city less friendly for cars now almost a
quarter of the Dutch population cycles
every day with 75 percent of children's
cycling to secondary school the number
of cyclists on the road also makes it
safer research shows a correlation
between higher numbers of bikes and
lower casualties among cyclists if
Amsterdam's story is anything to go by
there's not only safety but also power
in numbers just as important as cycling
lanes and car controls is getting people
on bikes in the first place
[Music]
you
you